foreign
and welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel
this session will be about python
automation projects for 2022 but before
we begin let me inform you about our
Channel's daily update on multiple
Technologies if you love The Hunt for
technological stuff consider subscribing
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update we from Simply learn bring you
this beautifully designed organized and
upgraded python automation projects for
2022. now let's get started for today's
schedule
first we will learn how to automate
WhatsApp messages using pi rocket module
next we will learn to automate sending
emails in this automation process we
will learn the usage of SMTP Library the
implementation of HTML tags and how to
send emails with attachments our final
project will be on how to automate the
download of images in a folder hello
everyone today we are here to discuss a
project on Python and how python can be
used to invoke and send messages in
WhatsApp
so what we are going to today do is
we're going to demonstrate you how to
use Pi watt kit it's a python utility
which is available in order for you to
interact directly with the pi Python and
WhatsApp
so we will show you certain examples
using which you can directly interface
with your WhatsApp now in order to
perform this activity first you need to
go to your python installation folder
now in my case I have my python
installed in my app data local programs
python python310 so your first task is
to go and open a command prompt from
this folder
and then you need to install pip install
Pi what kit so under python310 there is
a folder script and you paste this
command
and you should get this particular
message if you have already installed by
what kit if not then python will install
the relevant library in your computer
after you have done this then go back to
your python root folder
go to the python terminal
and then run the command import Pi what
kit
okay so after you have installed the
piwotkit library then you need to import
the pivot kit and this message should be
successfully imported
now I want to send a WhatsApp message
to a phone number
and I want to send it at a particular
time so right now I'll just set the time
as 20 38.
and please make sure that you are
already logged in to your
web.whatsapp.com and so that you know uh
the when python tries to send a message
you are already pre-logged in okay
okay so now if you see with this message
with this API I'm gonna send the message
at 8 39 so this will go and open the
WhatsApp window in next 46 seconds and
after 20 seconds the message will be
delivered so 8 39 so when the timer in
my system clock will reach to this
particular time
python will open a WhatsApp window log
into that reach to this phone number
which is there in my WhatsApp contacts
and then after 20 seconds this message
will be delivered so let's just wait for
few seconds and wait for python to
perform that activity
yes now python has opened the
web.whatsapp.com in which I'm already
logged in it has reached out to that
number and type the message welcome to
Simply learn world and I can send this
message
foreign
to the another example if I want to send
a message to a WhatsApp group then you
need a WhatsApp group chat ID and the
message you want to send so now in order
to send a message to the WhatsApp group
you can pick any
WhatsApp group in which you are
administrator
go to the group info and
click invite to group via a link
and in this link copy
copy this part copy link go to notepad
just copy this part this is the group ID
okay and paste it over here
okay
so now you can
send message to a group
copy paste this
in your command prompt
set the timing
in 16 seconds WhatsApp will open a
window and after 30 seconds the message
will be delivered
okay so WhatsApp window is open
it will reach out to that particular
group
it will type the message
and submit it
and even it will close the window
automatically now okay so this
particular
command has typed the message submitted
it and closed the window
now if you want to send the WhatsApp
message instantly
you just
use the API send what's message
instantly
and it will send it instantly to the
user
foreign
now another utility is that if you want
to
find a keyword
on YouTube
so we'll just play
on YouTube Simply learn on YouTube so
it will automatically play the YouTube
channel which you have put in that
particular keyword on the YouTube so
python can also directly open a YouTube
url or if you want to do a Google search
here you go so as soon as you put that
command on the python console it will
open google.com and search it
and today we are going to discuss about
how to send emails using python
so we will see the piece of code in our
jupyter notebook that how can we
leverage python as a programming
language to connect
with SMTP server email servers and send
emails
to the desired recipient simple emails
emails with attachment Etc so we will
see with certain examples
now before we move ahead just make sure
that whatever email ID we are going to
use for sending emails so we are going
to use our Gmail so make sure in your
Gmail
you have allowed less secure app access
and that's after this
if you have enabled this after that only
you will be able to send email using
python so please make sure that you have
enabled this less secure app access
okay
so we are going to use our Gmail account
as an example so that's why we are doing
this
now let's
start
so first of all you have to import
the relevant python Library which is the
SMTP lib and SSL Library okay
and then you need to mention the sender
email and the password
of your email ID
then provide the details of the
receivers whom all you want to send the
email okay
then we will
enter the details of the email body the
data which we want to send in an email
to the receiver now coming to
connectivity with the email server now
at this point we are utilizing this
utility SSL to create a context and
after this we will make connection with
the Gmail server and by default the SSL
Gmail server is running on Port 465
then we will login
and then send an email
okay so we need to connect to the
Gmail's SMTP outgoing mail server then
we need to provide the login information
and then send email so now when I will
execute this point
now I will try to check
my inbox and if you can see there is an
email which I have received just now
that and which has this is the content
this email is sent using Python and
subject is mail from Simply learn so
this is the
it's very simple piece of code which
allows you to send email from your
python code now let's take a look at
another example where we will try to
send email in an HTML body right
okay so similarly we will start by
importing SMTP lab and SSL
but also we will add two new libraries
which is mine text and multi-part now
because we are trying to send uh email
in a HTML body part so I'm going to
provide the email addresses of the
sender and the receiver so I'm going to
send email to myself
I'll take my password as an input
okay
now I have to provide the multi my
multi-part which I'm going to provide as
alternative subject as anything which
you can put multi-part test sender email
in the receiver email
now I'm creating a text and an HTML body
part
so this is an HTML body which will go in
my email
now I am creating two variables one in
which I'm defining my text part which is
text plane and another part I am adding
my HTML which is I am tagging as HTML
now you attach both part one
and part two
in the message
okay so now your message has both text
and the HTML
now thereafter
you have to create the same connectivity
with your SMTP Gmail
login
and then you have provided the details
of the sender and the receiver now you
have to apply message dot as underscore
string so now this is the sub this is
the difference from a previous example
where now you have encapsulated the HTML
in the text part encapsulated in a
message and then you are converting into
a string and sending
now now I have received an email
multi-part test if you see this is an
HTML body
where I have kept this as a header and
this as a plain text we are sending
email using python so if you see this
has come in bold as a header and this
has come as a plain text
okay
now another important aspect any email
generally you also need flexibility to
add an attachment to it okay so right
now what we have done is we have just
created the email body in a different
style earlier we had a plain text now
here we uh created the body in HTML now
we want to attachment
so what we will do is we'll say import
email SMTP lab SSL
now you have to import packages of
encoders mime base my multipart and mime
text
okay
now my other variables and email with
attachment from python this is my
subject
this is an email with attachment sent
from python this is the body sender and
receivable in email and password
now I'll put all these variables
encapsulate in a message which is my
multi-part okay the from details the two
details subject and the receiver email
foreign
and now I'm going to define the name of
the file which I want to attach now make
sure like I'm running this python script
from my
folder
you see Drive
users parijay and in this folder I have
a document called document.pdf which I
have kept it already so you make sure
that the document is lying in the same
folder from where you're running the
script
and then you have to
open the file attach the file to the
payload in octet stream
then you need to encode it in the base64
okay and then add header content
description with the file attachment and
the file name this is essential
then at this part now your part is ready
you have encapsulated the entire
attachment in the part and you've
attached that part to the message
convert the message as string
now you are at a point of creating
connection with the SMTP server
sender email receiver email and the text
part
and you need to send it
now if you go to your email this is the
document PDF which has come as an
attachment and you received it
so we have seen three variations of how
you can send email from python one
same plain simple vanilla email with
simple text
second you are sending email with HTML
body where you can use the HTML tags
third sending email with attachment
the common part between all the three
parts is that you need to create a
connectivity with the SMTP server
okay
and provide your credentials of the
sender email
and the data which you want to send in
the attachment
in other two cases where you were
sending HTML body we used mind text and
mind multipart and in the attachment
part we use my base as an extra Library
which we are supposed to use in order to
send an attachment
today we are gonna discuss about how we
can leverage python as a programming
language in order to automate
downloading of images
from a web page or Google search
so we will see what all python libraries
and utilities are required in order to
perform that activity
so this is primarily an automation
activity which you can perform in Python
where you want to download certain
amount of data certain images we are
taking images as an example over here so
how can you scrap a web page download
the images automatically in a particular
folder
now
what we are going to do is we are using
the selenium utility the selenium
package in Python in order to perform
this activity
so what we are going to do is we do
we're going to import selenium package
and then from selenium we are going to
import these libraries Webdriver
buy then if we are going to import
requests IO
import image and time okay so these are
the relevant libraries which you're
going to use in this particular example
now for executing this example you need
a particular Chrome driver as we're
going to use Chrome uh we're gonna
download this chrome driver so in order
to download the Chrome driver you need
to go to this URL of chrome
driver.chromium.org downloads
and please download the latest version
if you respect uh depending on what
operating system you're operating on so
I am using Chrome driver with 32 so I'll
download the Windows driver
and unzip it at the relevant folder so
wherever you're going to unzip the
Chrome driver.exe file please give the
path over here
and then initialize that
using the Webdriver utility which you
have imported
okay
so this is the initialization and you
can see a Chrome browser has got opened
now we are going to create a function
called get images from Google
and
we are going to write a
internal function which will scroll down
which will scroll through that
particular browser to a particular
position and
at a particular delay it will start
downloading the data
now
as a sample what we have done is we have
embedded a tree search a tree image
search Google search in my URL
so this
so this search will automatically get
opened from my python script
automatically so you'll see that
add
then
I'm gonna run that in a loop and put
that image URLs as a set
now I'm right I'm going to write a loop
how many images I want to download by
that I'm going to run a while loop on
the particular function and
write the piece of code in order to
download
till the time my Max images have been
reached now I will
find Elements by class name Q4 l u w d
okay
foreign
thumbnails I'll start
clicking that image so I'm using the
selenium utility over here I'm clicking
the image and then I'm getting the
source attribute of the image URLs and
then downloading it so this entire
function actually allows you to download
the image
and then I have a function which is the
download function
now I'm going to download images
from the web page I want four Images now
please make sure that you have provided
a path
so I have created a folder called C
drive
images folder in which I am gonna
download my
images
now my script is running it is
downloading the images and if I go into
the images folder
foreign
see the images have started to get
download and four Images the parameters
which I have passed are getting utilized
and if I want to quit it
now my program has got quit so if you
see this the browser
from where the images were starting to
get downloaded got open automatically
and now as I have quit the program it
got closed
and here are the four Images randomly
which has been picked from that
particular search and added
so I've killed the connection so that's
why that's why this error is coming
with that we have come to the end of
this session I hope it was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section also
subscribe to our Channel and stay tuned
for more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here